rangers starting pitcher mike fulton
making his 14th start one and seven so
horizon is aboard and that'll bring up
jorge polanco
and he continues his hot hitting the
throw going to second base and a rise is
barely in there ahead of gallows throw
tough read for the runner so two walks
and a single and it's white knuckle time
for fulton already let's see if nelson
cruz can get a competitive pitch to
swing at
it's going on and hit off his hands and
into right field that's a base hit
scooped up by gallo no throw for a rise
it'll be cut middle the diamond by low
rbi single on an o2 pitch for nelson
cruz and it's one nothing minnesota
kepler back in the lineup off the
injured list
[Applause]
roller to the right side
they'll get one and kepler beats the
relay it'll be a run batted in polanco
scoring and it's two to nothing larnick
down to third and they're on the bookend
corners for ryan jeffers
jeffers dribbles it slowly up the line a
run will score
jeffers is safe at first the flip from
the pitcher pulled low off the base
and it's three to nothing good break
from third by the runner larnick he was
going to score anyway but then fulton
evac threw high to first base now looks
kirloff danny is the seventh man to bat
here's the ball cracked right back to
the hill faulty has it goes to second
for one is he to first double play
that's one six three that'll get him out
of the inning but the damage is done
jose barrios taking his 14th start he's
throwing the ball really well the last
month hopefully that's what we see
continue from him
hard ground ball that one in the left
field base hit for tyner falefa that's a
good way to start the bottom of the
first here's nate london two strike
pitch swung on a missed jose barrio
struck him out out number one recorded
nate lowe scouting report right now
struggling to hit fastballs and breos
takes advantage four pitch walk to
gallow and that'll bring solace to the
plate as the tying run
on the ground and that one is still in
the left field of base hit solace gets a
run to the plate and the rangers
immediately chip away against barrios a
big
two out single by nick solac here's
willy calhoun left-handed hitting d-h
25th pitch of the inning and that one
lined into left field that's a base hit
gallow around third base he's headed to
the plate he scores and the throwback to
second not in time to get solace and
it's a one-run game
another big two-out hit this one by
calhoun now the tying run at second for
eli white 1-0 pitch on the ground
towards short backhand pickup polanco
short way to second for the fourth shot
and the inning is done but like the
twins seven men bat for texas they play
two one busy gaining a baseball like
globe life field it's 3-2 in favor of
minnesota he goes after the first pitch
and lines it to right and a sliding grab
out there by joey gallo what a good
defense in the second and he gets that
first down that's a great catch from
joey gallo it's not an easy dive when
you're coming in on an angle like that
and you get caught in between and you
got to make that decision austin dio
he's at first base and that will bring
up the veteran jorge polanco
that one's hit up the alley in left
center field on the move though is eli
white he covers the ground well closes
in and makes a running grab in left
center for retired polanco he had to
work hard in the first and he gave up a
couple of runs now he's got to work hard
again here in the second and the runners
are now at first and second so two on
two out now for adolesce garcia who
flied out the center his first time all
right goodness 55th pitch for carrillos
and the last one of the second inning
rangers leave two aboard the twins still
lead by one both he needed 26 pitches in
the first just 12 in the second first
it's trevor lonick's turn and swinging
amazing puts larnick away there a
change-up well outside the zone he got
larnick chasing and for fulton evac it's
his first strike out of the ball game
here to start off the top of the third
there's a swing and a miss and cruz
strikes out two away back-to-back case
for colton
swinging a miss he gets him with a
changeup
that one went down and in kepler chases
and how about this mike fultonevich
strikes out the side in order
hoping to have the type of ending that
fulton nevich had
and the changeup puts him away good
pitch to a fastball hitter and a good
spot two down for barrios three two
swung on a missed another breaking ball
and down goes calhoun so lightfold and
evidence perform barrio settles down and
buzzes through the heart of the order
twins cooking here in the top of the
fourth leading three to two they've got
none of the corners with one out for
willian's ass studio swinging a bouncing
ball to short could be two kinder pull
up at a second for one so left but first
scooped fire reaching up the line in
time for the double play and the rangers
get out of the jam unscathed oh brock
holt will bat rio's had a one two three
third but now the tying run at first
with nobody out first pitch is swung on
and that one's hit to left center field
dropping and falls for a base circle
white hits the bag at seventy that's the
third the throw goes two seconds so
they sit for brock holt and the rangers
cooking here in the bottom of the fourth
none of the corners and nobody out so
here's jose trevino and he hits this one
in the air center field gordon goes back
this should be deep enough to score a
run it will white tags he scores holt
tags he heads to second a sack five for
trevino and he's tied the game at three
apiece the rangers now the corners we're
tied at three here in the bottom of the
fourth and adobe's garcia a chance to
give the rangers a lead and strong miss
got him
so barrios
pitches out of a jam here three hits two
left on we're through four two down on
the fifth and now trevor learning
walking a run scorer to the first a
swinging strikeout in the third
larnick tees off to right field a long
home run to put the twins back in front
trevor larnick with his fourth and the
twins lead it four to three there's your
jet stream if you don't have one create
your own river logic had done 15 games
without a home run and he caught all of
that ball and elise garcia hits in four
straight he's hitless tonight
for garcia but he hits this one in the
air keep out to right it is
[Applause]
but he's tied it up in the seventh with
his 17th home run of the year here at
one and two alkali threw a fastball at
100 good solid contact there by garcia
sending it the other way we'll go to the
ninth inning and jeffers is on with a
pop-up single to start the twins night
and now here's alex kiriloff right
here's o2 this one on the ground first
base they'll go to second for one back
to low at first and that one gets away
heading for two he could be in trouble
here comes the throw
got him at second base
an unconventional double play but a
beauty three six three four six double
play dave
well now you have
and this is a tough
double play to try to turn but a great
job by nick scholak to slide and throw
it in how about the pick from isaiah
connor on the back end with the runner
crossing right in front of him that is
tremendous concentration and a good job
by ikf to get the tag on kiriloff as
he's sliding into second base and gordon
is the go ahead run at second base so
now pasta dio
a swing and a miss
and he has struck out osteo to end the
inning
and now the rangers with a chance to win
it in the bottom of the ninth bottom of
the ninth inning hansel robles is on for
the minnesota twins so here's lowe who
has been on board twice officially one
for three pitch number 11 in the attack
tie game bottom nine hesitates delivers
swung on ground ball right towards
polanco picked it up it rolled up his
chest and he throws to first to get the
out we've played nine we haven't solved
the thing let's play extras and it'll be
the top of the batting order starting
with the rise with asta deal the runner
at second base
there's a drive to center field
garcia going back and he won't get there
off the wall oscar dia will score
losing the helmet as he rounds third and
going to third is luisa
with one of the biggest hits for the
twins this year
a run scoring triple means the twins
have a 5-4 lead
crews intentionally walked and that sets
up kepler faces loaded and only one out
oh two
swinging in the miss
strikes him out on an elevated fastball
possibly above the zone a borderline
pitch
now jeffers
and he took ball four it's a bases
loaded walk a rise comes in from third
base demarcus evans has come on to pitch
and the bases are refilled now for
kirilov 3-2 bounced up to handball four
twins will take another run they lead it
7-4
trots home
the red is charged to spores
it's the fourth walk of the unit bottom
of the tent the twin seven the rangers
four the runner up the third here comes
joey gallo first pitch joey swings in a
broken back flare to short center field
that drops for a hit
low comes home to score so joey gallo an
rbi single it's now seven to five
minnesota they're on the corners two out
and it's eli white taken for a cold
strike three duffy pounds his glove
white heads back to the dugout and the
minnesota twins hang a win in texas